l'instruction de la sphère du meurtre du
petit grégory se poursuit à epinal hier
juge d'instruction a reçu la mère de
l'enfant assassiné nos auditions qui
pose bien des questions
pascal guimier 36 jours après la mort du
petit grégory l'enquète semble piétiner
hier plusieurs témoins entendus par le
juge d'abord christine et jean marie
villemin les parents de la victime
ensuite michel villemin l'oncle de
l'enfant c'est d'après le témoignage de
christine et de michel que les gendarmes
ont pu établir la chronologie exacte des
événements et ceci dès le début de la
faire tout ce serait donc passé entre 17
heures et 17 heures 26 le 16 octobre
dernier à 17 heures selon sa mère
l'enfant jouait devant la maison à 17h26
l'oncle recevait un appel du corbeau
revendiquant le crime
les gendarmes continuent de vérifier
l'emploi du temps des villemin et de
leurs proches pour ne rien laisser au
hasard
quatre jeunes femmes ont également été
entendu hier par le juge
trois d'entre elles seraient des
collègues de travail de christine
villemin
elle affirme l'avoir vu poster une
lettre le jour même du crime alors même
où le corbeau envoyée cette dernière
lettre
la mère de l'enfant elle après trois des
positions contradictoires affirmant que
c'était la veille